[Música]
ya son al menos 40 las personas
fallecidas a causa del paso de la
tormenta gélida helio que ha afectado
gran parte de Estados Unidos en la zona
urbana de Búfalo en el estado de Nueva
York siete personas perdieron la vida
tendremos reporte de la situación en
minutos
y cerca de 70 aeronaves militares chinas
han incursionado en el espacio aéreo de
Taiwán en las últimas 24 horas el hecho
ha generado preocupación en la región
del Pacífico se trata de la mayor
incursión militar china en cielos de
Taiwán que tiene lugar recientemente
y por segundo día consecutivo miles de
personas protestaron contra el bloqueo
por parte de azerbaiyán del único
corredor terrestre que une a la
autoproclamada República de astash con
el mundo exterior que ha estado
bloqueada ya por 15 días provocando
desabastecimiento
muy buenas noches Bienvenidos a las
noticias de France 24 soy Santiago López
González Gracias por estar con nosotros
hasta ahora
ya son al menos 40 las personas que han
fallecido a causa del paso de la
tormenta Elliot que ha afectado buena
parte de los estados de la Unión
Americana con fuertes vientos Nevadas y
bajas temperaturas las condiciones
climáticas extremas afectaron acerca del
60% de la población de Estados Unidos
justamente en las celebraciones de
Navidad en la zona de Búfalo en el
estado de Nueva York siete personas
perdieron la vida y parte de la ciudad
ha colapsado por cuenta de la nieve que
se ha acumulado allí con las intensas
Nevadas nos comunicamos a esta hora con
John García él es Sheriff del Condado de
iris en la zona de Búfalo allí en el
estado de Nueva York oficial García
Gracias por estar con nosotros aquí en
France 24 ya lo estaba mencionando yo
siete muertos hasta el momento y parte
de la ciudad ha colapsado debido a la
gran cantidad de nieve que ha caído allí
Qué dispositivo hay a esta hora para
ayudar entonces a los más afectados y
reactivar la actividad normal de la
ciudad
Pues bueno buenas tardes
puedo confirmar que tenemos ahora mismo
a 28 fallecidos por la la tormenta y
y veremos al final que es el balance de
muertos por esta tormenta no soy
optimista porque
vamos a ir de casa a casa a ver y
vamos a chequear con con los barrios a
ver cómo están los ancianos y esos que
necesitan ayuda médica Pero eso eso no
fue una tormenta Esto fue como una bomba
que cayó y los vientos a más de 70
millas por hora la nieve y el frío
porque aquí en Batman tenemos en el
viendo Muchas veces tenemos seis siete
pies de nieve pero esto Esto fue algo
que jamás se ha visto
oficial García Gracias por estar con
nosotros en France 24 retomo algunas de
sus palabras 18 fallecidos ya
confirmados por las autoridades de esta
localidad de Búfalo en el estado de
Nueva York también en las últimas 24
horas cerca de 70 aviones de la fuerza
aérea de China incluidas aeronaves de
combate y drones entraron en la zona de
defensa aérea de Taiwán así lo reportó
el gobierno de La Isla que indicó que se
trataría de la mayor incursión militar
china en espacio aéreo taiwanés
naves del ejército chino entre ellas
drones y aviones de combate como de
costumbre china Está realizando sus
maniobras militares en el estrecho de
Taiwán imágenes propagandísticas y
maniobras que pretenden presionar a las
autoridades de taipei que dice seguir de
cerca la situación 47 de estos aviones
cruzaron la línea del estrecho de Taiwán
y entraron en la zona de defensa aérea
de La Isla se trata de la tercera mayor
incursión registrada desde principios de
año china ha realizado más de 1700
ejercicios de este tipo Beijing culpa a
las autoridades taiwanesas de
provocaciones y colisionar con Estados
Unidos el sábado china manifestó su
firme oposición a un proyecto de ley de
defensa estadounidense que permitía
destinar hasta 10 mil millones de
dólares en ayuda militar Taiwán La Isla
aspira a independizarse de su vecino
chino pero Beijing pretende reunificar
su territorio Washington reconoce la
unidad de China pero mantiene estrechos
lazos con Taiwán desde hace décadas las
tensiones aumentaron cuando Nancy pelosi
de la cámara de representantes de
Estados Unidos visitó La Isla a
principios de agosto desde entonces las
relaciones diplomáticas entre Beijing y
Washington se han deteriorado aún más la
presidenta
taiwanesay convocó Este martes un
consejo de seguridad para estudiar la
posibilidad de reforzar el sistema de
defensa civil de su territorio
alguna corrección son 28 ya las personas
fallecidas en el condado de Búfalo en el
estado de Nueva York se suma entonces a
esas cifras parciales de más de 40
personas fallecidas por cuenta de esta
tormenta en Estados Unidos cambiamos de
tema Hablamos ahora de El caucaso miles
de personas salieron a las calles del
centro de estepanaquel la capital de la
autoproclamada República de hashtag en
nagorno caravag los manifestantes
rechazan el bloqueo por parte de los
activistas de azerbaiyán de la única vía
de acceso terrestre que tiene la región
lo que ha llevado a una grave crisis de
desabastecimiento de alimentos y de
medicinas el informe es de Andrés
triviño
en multitudinarias protestas miles de
personas salieron a las calles de esta
panaker la capital del autoproclamada
República dearstage por un bloqueo al
corredor lachin la única vía que conecta
la disputada región de nagorno carabajas
con Armenia
Este es el único camino que conecta
artage con el resto del mundo no solo
Armenia llegamos al resto del mundo a
través de Armenia la situación es muy
grave pero la gente sin embargo intenta
aguantar
la autoproclamada República de astash se
encuentra ubicada en la frontera entre
azerbaiyán y Armenia pero es habitada
por una mayoría étnica Armenia Por lo
cual es territorio de disputa
internacional
el corredor la china ha sido bloqueada
durante casi dos semanas por
manifestantes azerbaellanos que
protestan en contra de las minas
ilegales de la zona Pero los dos países
entraron en una guerra en el otoño de
2020 por el control de la ruta Armenia
acusa a azerbaiyán de querer provocar
una crisis humanitaria
los habitantes de la zona ya empiezan a
sentir los estragos de casi dos semanas
de bloqueos
casas de medicamentos alimentos para
bebé pañales medicamentos para la
presión para adultos no podemos atender
a todos adecuadamente liberamos los
medicamentos en pequeñas cantidades
los bloqueos del corredor Vial han
aumentado el temor de una nueva guerra
en la región en septiembre de 2022 los
combates en la frontera entre ambos
países dejaron cerca de 300 muertos
y la ciudad de Estambul en Turquía de
cerca de 16 millones de habitantes y
dividida entre dos continentes allí tal
vez desplazarse puede ser un reto diario
para los ciudadanos sin embargo la
metrópolis turca tiene un medio de
transporte particular que se destaca
estamos hablando de los populares
ferries que por el mismo valor de un
boleto del metro permite cruzar el
estrecho del bósforo que separa a Europa
de Asia o viceversa Adriana rocha y
Alberta naya tiene la historia
Hace seis años que el capitán bunjamin
dirige el ferry beykoz por estas costas
se conoce el bósforo y Estambul a la
perfección
Pese a que esta vía marítima es una de
las más transitadas y difíciles del
mundo bunyamín disfruta tranquilo de su
trabajo
A veces curioseamos si vemos un carguero
muy grande Cuántos metros mide qué
longitud tiene a través del sistema lo
vemos también Hacia dónde va
el bacon es una de las decenas de ferez
que cada día transitan constantemente
entre Asia y Europa los dos continentes
que convergen en Estambul Todo bajo una
de las vistas más famosas del mundo en
las entrañas del barco sin embargo harum
no las puede disfrutar
modo arte que al estar acostumbrado ya
no miro donde estoy si Hemos salido del
bósforo o no me he acostumbrado también
a estas vistas Aunque mi trabajo esté
debajo del agua
más arriba los pasajeros disfrutan de lo
que ven a través de las ventanas
antes los ferries eran la única forma de
ir al otro lado
ahora carreteras puentes túneles y
metros unen las orillas de Estambul los
barcos se han convertido en un
transporte de nostalgia la música lo
recorre
el trayecto se convierte en algo
divertido al mismo tiempo la gente Mira
las vistas mientras escucha música en
directo bebe su té y en 20 minutos han
cruzado el continente por las otras vías
Hay mucho tráfico
en una metrópoli de 16 millones el
bósforo y sus transeúntes de hierro son
un oasis de tranquilidad lejos del ruido
de la ciudad de tráfico y motores
de estas aguas el trayecto se convierte
en un viaje al pasado
esto en las noticias buenas noches
[Música]